[Music]
kovat 19 is transforming people's
relationship to work with millions now
out of a job and many more getting used
to working in a very different way the
proportion of Americans working from
home full-time has gone from 1 in 50 to
more than 1 in 3 Kovac has been the
transformation and that raises a whole
bunch of questions do you need as much
expensive obvious space and do
individual workers need to commute into
the office every day the need for
workers to gather together in offices
has shaped almost every aspect of modern
life and the shift towards remote
working could have far-reaching
consequences it could alter the shape
and purpose of cities affect gender
equality and even change how we think
about time
the modern office emerged along with the
Industrial Revolution when people
migrated to cities in search of work
factories required everybody to be
together so they could take advantage of
the powered machinery that started to
bring everybody into cities where they
could work together and easily walk to
the place where they were working that
in turn led to the growth of the offices
to manage all those companies early
offices were organized into rows of
desks for Clarks overseen by a central
manager mirroring the production line on
the factory floor and 200 years later
despite the rise of the Internet the
basic function of the office persists
we made the leap from seeing that people
could communicate via electronic means
by email by shared documents without
realizing that didn't mean that
everybody had to be in the same place
you've got mail we've had 20 odd years
since the internet and office design is
really only starting to reflect the real
possibilities of that change the
uncomfortable truth about offices is
that they are expensive and inefficient
company spend on average ten thousand
dollars on office space per employee
every year the most expensive office
real estate is in Hong Kong where every
square foot costs on average two hundred
and sixty-five dollars per year Beijing
and London are the next most expensive
locations the need for social distancing
in the wake of the pandemic could reduce
the number of staff in London offices by
two-thirds making the office look like
an expensive artifact I've talked to
companies that say they're thinking of
maybe using two floors in the building
instead of four or maybe using regional
offices as small sub offices so that not
everybody has to commute into a big city
the idea of workers clocking in and out
at the same time every day also dates
back to the Industrial Revolution before
that people were paid based on how much
they made rather than the amount of time
they spent at work and if the office
ceases to be the center of working life
the idea of working set hours or the
nine-to-five
will become less meaningful we may will
work on a Sunday or Saturday afternoon
if that's more convenient for us we're
shifting back again to people being paid
for their function and not for the time
they turn up
tech companies are leading the charge
towards remote working twitter has
already said its staff need never come
back to the office if they don't want to
and facebook says half its staff could
be working remotely in a decade these
types of high skill highly paid roles
have a disproportionate impact on the
economy they are known as knowledge jobs
and where they are physically located is
important as they support entire
ecosystems of other jobs around them for
every knowledge job by other jobs that
are dependent on that some of these are
very high skills like lawyers and
doctors jobs like baristas Huber
instructors and other sort of urban
services once you add up a syllabus that
they contribute the majority of
Americans are employed in a way it means
that they dependent on knowledge jobs
although it's impossible to know exactly
how many other roles are supported by
these so-called knowledge jobs if they
were to become remote positions it would
have a profound impact on the jobs they
support in the wider economy but this
isn't a one-way street knowledge jobs
are such powerful drivers of the economy
because they are usually based in cities
[Music]
because they million people are more
than 50 percent more productive than
ones living in metros with smaller
populations the question for knowledge
workers is whether you can replicate
those productivity benefits with a
looser relationship to a city or to
there's no relationship to a city those
able to work from home are a privileged
minority and in general the higher a
country's GDP per head the more people
are able to work remotely in Cambodia
just eleven percent of jobs can be done
from home compared with 45 percent in
switzerland or 37 percent in America
but the work from home revolution is
having a particularly pronounced effect
on some groups within the workforce
women are more likely to work in
face-to-face roles and so they have been
disproportionately affected by the
recession caused by covert nineteen in
previous recessions men have generally
been more likely to be laid off as they
are over-represented in manufacturing
and construction this time around more
women in America have lost their jobs
and those who've kept their jobs have
extra challenges mothers are now
interrupted over 50% more often than
fathers but the normalization of home
working during the pandemic could also
have long-term benefits for some female
workers each remote way of working that
has no secret activates then I think
that it might be a good thing so we're
going to sort of help them break through
although offices are sitting empty
corporate leases can run for as long as
a decade and there has not yet been a
rush to sell office real estate so the
office in some form looks set to survive
the pandemic the global experiment in
remote working has shown there are some
things that are hard to foster online
like corporate culture and creativity
and these will be the mainstays of the
post pandemic office that's about all I
got to say Don good job of saying it
or younger workers they make friends and
connections and network where they can
get on in life later on it's very hard
to build a kind of a spree decor in a
company for people who haven't met
offices will be less of a prison cell
and more of a collaborative area more of
a games room where you go in to try and
shoot the breeze with your colleagues
and come up with something different it
may feel like the pandemic has
revolutionized working life but in some
ways it has simply come full circle
before the Industrial Revolution there
was no working weep no nine-to-five or
fixed workplace for many people and
thanks to covert 19 this may be closer
to the way things will look when the
world emerges from lockdown
I'm Vlatko behind
Bartleby colonists of The Economist
covering management and work if you'd
like to read more about Kobe 19 and its
effect on working life click the link
opposite
[Music]